Neil has created a new demonstration to
illustrate an explosion of green
hydrogen Brady didn't know that there
were even colors of hydrogen
this doesn't mean the color of the gas
but these are terms that have been
introduced quite recently to describe
the way that hydrogen is made
the sustainability of the production
method
traditionally the industrial production
of hydrogen is from methane reacting
with steam and it produces hydrogen and
carbon dioxide
so from the point of view of climate
change it's very bad because the CO2 is
released that is called gray hydrogen
now there is a variation in which you do
the same reaction but you capture the
CO2 and bury it under the ground or
under the sea and then it's called Blue
hydrogen then you can make hydrogen by
electrolysis passing electric current
through water containing something that
makes it slightly more electrically
conducting than pure water
Neil used a small amount of sulfuric
acid for the process but there are a
variety of things you can add hydrogen
that is made by passing electricity from
a nuclear power station is called pink
hydrogen
well some people call it purple hydrogen
and then there is green hydrogen which
is also made by electrolysis but making
the electricity from a renewable source
wind turbine or solar energy Neil has a
solar panel outside the building
attached to a wire that comes out of his
lab so that he can have the panel in the
sunlight and the other end of the wire
is attached to battery
because the Sun goes in and out
and just to give a more stable
electrical supply and then that battery
is connected to a terrific apparatus
that is built out of junk pieces of
glassware that he found in the lab that
was being emptied wires from the battery
are attached to two Platinum electrodes
electrodes made out of thin pieces of
platinum metal the current goes through
the water all right I'm ready
foreign
oxygen at one electrode hydrogen at the
other electrode it bubbles up and into
his green balloon
initially it seemed to inflate very
slowly
and then while Brady and I were out of
the room Neil found a leak and after
that it increased it to considerably
better pace
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
and then with the match on the stick it
went with a big bang
[Music]
and a quite a loud bang because the
hydrogen and the oxygen were not
separated so there was a hydrogen oxygen
mixture in just the right proportions to
moles of hydrogen to one mole of oxygen
so that you make water with a nice Bang
[Music]
it demonstrates the principle very
nicely how you can use sunlight to
generate hydrogen
which in principle could be used to fuel
road vehicles heat houses and so on
though I think you'd need a rather more
efficient apparatus than eels to get the
thing to work there is one extra twist
that when we looked up to check that we
got the right colors for hydrogen
people have now started talking about
yellow hydrogen which is hydrogen made
from electricity from solar energy
so Neil's hydrogen perhaps rather than
being green is actually yellow but he
didn't have a balloon that was both
green and yellow
now the thing that really excited Brady
was gold hydrogen
and gold hydrogen is very rare and this
is naturally occurring hydrogen that you
can find in deposits under the ground
you drill a hole and out comes hydrogen
and that is produced by very hot steam
generated by the heat of the earth
reacting with a metal such as iron in
minerals so that you get iron oxide and
hydrogen
now in principle it's wonderful you
drill a hole and out comes hydrogen the
drawback is that there are not many
deposits of gold hydrogen and they're in
really isolated places thousands of
miles from where you might actually want
to use the hydrogen
but it does so that nature sometimes
produces hydrogen
and if we had to make energy carriers
that are sustainable green hydrogen like
Neil is making could be the way forward
of course nature does produce hydrogen
on a pretty Grand scale we're just not
here on Earth to well
um there's a lot of hydrogen out there
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe
but unfortunately
it's most of it is not here
and so
it is rather like the cows looking over
the fence and seeing the grass being
greener on the other side
the hydrogen is greener out in space but
we can't get it
why not become a hydrogen supporter of
periodic videos like these people here
or maybe you want to choose another
element
the whole table awaits you there are
details on screen and in the video
description
[Music]